today's one minute monday
is stay top of mind what you want to do
is think about your network
and the people who are around your
business and find ways to
to stay top of mind so that they keep
thinking about you
and uh they keep finding ways to help
you grow your business so here's a quick
example
there's a friend of a friend of mine
named fabi saba you can look her up on
on twitter it's f-a-b-i-s-a-b-a
and she recently wrote a blog post about
how girls should not only be treated
like princesses but you could also make
them superheroes i think she made a
video on it
and so i came across a blog post to talk
about the same thing and so i forwarded
it on to her saying hey i thought you
might enjoy this
on top of that she's uh she's all about
empathy her one word is empathy and
she's trying to teach
parents and kids to have empathy towards
each other and using that as your
parenting style
and i came across a campaign called the
kind
campaign which was anti-bullying and
served kind of the same
audience and it really showed how
organization was using their one word
and making it a powerful movement
so it's kind campaign i think it's dot
com and i just voted it off to her and
so
and i'm doing this all the time and what
you want to do is when you
are connecting with people in your
network
find something about them that that they
love that they're interested in
and try to remember it in your
day-to-day activities right like i
haven't spoken to
fabi uh connect with her in a long time
and i came across his article sent it
off to her and now she's remembering me
again and
nothing may ever come of it that's cool
but if you do that enough with all the
people in your network
your name is going to stay top of mind
and you're going to get new business
you're going to have a lot more fun
and you're going to continue to grow so
that's one minute monday for today
if you guys like this video thumbs up
below you can subscribe and
leave a comment let me know what you
think take care